. I was browsing The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit this morning, which is just a few
hundred subscribers from 30000. You can join
the discussion at David Pakman dot com Reddit.
The user Blue Phal Sarda or Balcatta sounding
the alarm about what's going on in Brazil,
posting people in the United States and the world
are sleeping on the humanitarian crisis happening
in Brazil right now. Only country in the planet
hitting three thousand daily deaths. Right now
it is almost something biblical. As Sydney Powell
would say, Brazil has elected a true genocide as
president. I assume they mean a genocidal maniac.
It would take a long time to explain the disaster.
But he is singlehandedly responsible for more than
300000 deaths. He pushed hydroxy chloroquine. He
doesn't believe in vaccines, rejected 70 million
doses for Pfizer. Yeah, what's going on in Brazil
is is absolutely tragic. Brazil, I believe
they even had four thousand deaths in a day.
But you know what's really mean as it's a tragedy,
what's going on in Brazil? But Brazil still has,
as of now, a lower per capita case rate than
the United States overall for the pandemic and
a lower per capita death rate than the United
States. When you look at Brazil and you see how
deaths are spiking and things are completely
out of control, we handled this so much worse
than Brazil for much of the pandemic during 20,
under Donald Trump's leadership or lack thereof,
that our numbers pandemic worldwide are still
worse than Brazil is now because we're vaccinating
so much and Brazil is going in the wrong
direction. It's quite plausible that in four
weeks or in six weeks, Brazil's pandemic numbers
overall will be worse than ours. There's no
question about that. But it's just incredible to
think about that. Things were just such a disaster
in the U.S. for so long that as bad as things
are there, we're still worse off here. Overall,
if you look at deaths and cases per capita since
the start of the pandemic. Another interesting
post from user Hardan, 17, one who says, I watched
David talk to that Trump apologist woman earlier
and I have no idea how he maintains his composure
while being confronted with such supreme ignorance
and disinformation. Attached is an economic study
which shows Trump had little positive effect on
the economic boom during his tenure. Going on to
say, apart from her delusions about how hands on
and CEO like Trump was, she said one thing that
really pissed me off due to her gross inhumanity,
she told David. The immigration problem is no
longer Mexican and Central Americans entering
looking for jobs. She says the new challenge is
seven year olds making their way to the border
alone or with the help of coyotes and being dumped
in the United States. Her very next statement was,
if we don't solve this problem, it will have
consequences for working American jobs. Does she
mean from the seven year old unaccompanied minors?
Yeah, you know, I got a bunch of emails from the
interview with Republican strategist Amanda Mackey
earlier this week. And many of them pointed out,
David, you didn't push back on this. You
missed that insane thing. She said. I know.
She was just galloping me and it's difficult to
keep up, you know, you have to pick your battles,
you have to pick your battles. And so I focused
in on her claims about Trump being responsible
for the vaccines. I focused in on her weird claims
about how Trump's covid bills were bipartisan. But
Biden's weren't. You have to pick your
battles. And of course, I missed things and
I will try to do better next time. But I'm glad
that so many in the audience noticed that there
were way more things she said that made no
sense than the ones that I was able to call
out. Join the discussion at The David Pakman
Show. Subrata David Pakman Dotcom R.E.D. Ditty.